hi everyone I'm Rubio Soria I'm the
creative director of the order 1886 and
we're here to talk about the game I
believe madmoizelle requires our
attention the area we're demoing today
is uh is happening in Whitechapel it's
really a continuation of what we showed
in February we enter that sequence with
them being called out because there was
something happening outside what we see
here is really what happens and why you
called outside and the core gameplay
that we've been talking about all this
time so the the segment island of game
plane Whitechapel takes place very early
on I mean we've showed as the game
starts actually there's a there's a
little chapter title cut that comes in
in chapter 3 and it's called
inequalities I mean it's a it's very
telling that it's called inequalities
because here you are the knights of the
round table very much considered to be
defending the rich only you know in in
the society fighting against the poorer
of Whitechapel which is not really what
you want to do because you are trying to
protect them the thermite rifle actually
is an interesting weapon because if you
remember we showed that weapon a year
ago to the date it was shown at at the
e3 trailer and laughs I'd was using it
it was really a way for us to kind of
you know plant the seed in people's mind
and have them talk about it until we
could really demo what it did and today
in this demo we're really showing the
full power of it it's a cover buster
it's an amazing weapon you can literally
paint fire in the on the city and it's a
lot of fun to play with the interesting
thing is that there's a lot of research
out there about all these weapons
whether they existed like 40 50 60 years
ago or weapons that exist today or even
100 so years ago all of this is really
as much as possible based on real things
you find YouTube videos of things that
you would not believe we you know we
started working on the order now it's in
a little bit more than three years ago
with the intent of really delivering an
experience that was unique something
that people did not expect what these
really in gameplay but in narrative as
well we have a lot of work to do there's
always a lot of work to do I think
that's gonna be a lot of work to do the
day before we go gold but you know we
were targeting an early
fifteen release and really that that's
that's in order to deliver the
experience that we promise we will
deliver